i'm here at the very first crypto
connect event in miami sponsored by
future perfect ventures so today we have
a really exciting interview coming up
but before we jump into it i do want to
let you know that this particular
interview is sponsored by exodus wallet
so a huge thank you to exodus wallet
because without them we wouldn't be able
to bring you such great content so
exodus wallet is a next generation
digital marketplace and cryptocurrency
wallet very easy to use very easy to
download it's available on mobile it's
available on desktop you can use it on
android you can use it on iphone
whichever you prefer and to be honest
it's my number one pick when it comes to
cryptocurrency wallets
joining me today is the sec commissioner
hester pierce to give us the full
landscape or the relationship between
the sec and cryptocurrencies hester
great to have you how are you it's so
delightful to be here thanks for having
me and i have to start with my standard
disclaimer which is that my views
represent my own views not necessarily
those of the sec or my fellow
commissioners well i appreciate the
disclaimer we appreciate it and uh we're
really excited to have you here there's
a lot to discuss so i'm going to jump
straight into it and i do want to start
with the most recent piece of news which
was that van x spot etf was rejected so
can we we understand why that might have
been and also what do you look for when
you go to approve an etf
so as with many regulatory things this
is a little bit complicated that was a
staff decision and um the commission
that that's now been pulled up for the
commission to take a look at it
which means that i can't talk about that
particular one but what i can say is
that in the past what we've looked at is
is the bitcoin market the underlying
bitcoin market is that regulated in a
way that looks familiar to us as a
securities regulator
and so so far
with there have been a number of
applications and on all of them we've
come out and we've said no we don't
think so
over my dissent um i i will say that
i've i've written a couple dissents on
this um and and continue to be concerned
that
not making this kind of product
available to retail investors
is problematic um i think it's it's an
option that again depending on the facts
and circumstances it makes sense to make
this option available to people who want
it
of course there was the futures etf
which has been approved so can you
explain to me what the difference is
between the spot etf and the futures etf
and why it's harder to get that sport
etf through i know many people including
myself were a lot more excited for the
sport ethio
so the the point i made about us wanting
to have that market be regulated in the
way our markets are regulated
is is how we got to where we are with a
futures based product getting approved
the futures markets are regulated by the
commodity futures trading commission
and that's our sister regulator and
we're very comfortable with those
markets and so something built on top of
that looks really familiar to us and and
we can get comfortable with that
and there's a difference between an
exchange traded product which is a broad
category in an exchange traded fund
the futures based product that got
approved as an etf which means that it's
subject to this
special regulatory regime that's
intended to protect retail investors
and so
our new chair uh chair gary gensler
made it clear that people should come in
with id with with applications for
futures-based exchange-traded funds and
so indeed people came in and those were
approved so it's it's a step forward but
it's not the spot
product that a lot of people were
interested in seeing
that said there's been quite a bit of
interest investor interest in these
early futures based products
and given the amount of interest that we
are also seeing in that sport etf
how do you have a timeline that you can
share with us is that possible at all
you know i i've been asked that question
i've been at the sec four years and i've
been asked that question since virtually
the first day i started at the sec
and my my predictions i tend not to make
predictions i say i don't know
but i tell people
that sec time is definitely not like
crypto time it can take a very long time
and so i think again there's there's
no one should should be looking um
and expecting something to happen until
we get over this rationale that we've
been using which is i would argue a
different rationale for for the one
we've applied to similar products
based on other types of things
i'd like to understand from your
perspective what the sec sentiment is
towards cryptocurrencies because we have
seen a lot of um hostility perhaps from
the us government the lack of um clarity
in the infrastructure bill i know upset
the crypto community quite a lot um so
what is the sec's general sentiment
towards cryptos
well so i started out by saying that my
views represent my own and so the
commission is made up of five different
commissioners one of whom is the
chairman gary gensler
and we all have different perspectives
on all kinds of things and so
this is no no different right there
there are a whole
slew of different perspectives
and um
then there's the staff as well with
about 4 500 people and so there are a
lot of different
experiences and sets of expertise that
people bring when they look at something
like crypto
so there's no one view but that said
chair gensler is someone who spent
several years at mit teaching about
financial technology about
crypto specifically
and so he brings an understanding of the
potential for the space
he also is someone who really likes a
nice regulatory structure and so
i think that there are people who
want to see
innovation happen but they want it to
happen in a very regulated frame and and
that's what we're seeing some of and
then there there are people like me who
who say you know we need to develop
a regulatory framework that makes sense
and that that really
um allows innovation to happen and and
i'm i'm more worried about the objective
that we're meeting the objectives of
financial regulation which without
saying it has to look exactly like the
regulatory framework that we have on the
the non-crypto side so there's a
diversity of views and we'll see where
that ends up shaking out but i think the
positive is
that more people in washington are
spending more time thinking about crypto
and
you know certainly learning more about
it and that's that's going to be
positive i think at the end of the day
for for regulation
so it's all about that fine line between
stifling innovation and of course
protecting the investor there is concern
that it could potentially stifle
innovation within the us and america
really should be at the forefront of
this inevitable industry so what is the
sec doing to make sure that regulation
doesn't
make
america essentially fall behind the rest
of the world
well and i think it's important to
remember the sec is one of many
regulators in the united states that has
a potential interest in crypto so
we we have a piece to play in making
this a very innovation-friendly place
but it's not only our job
and our mission is to protect investors
to facilitate capital formation and to
maintain foster
efficient and orderly markets so that's
what we're thinking about when we go
about our job
i do agree with you that the us should
be the place that people want to come to
innovate it should be the place people
want to come to invest and build their
companies
um but we you know we have a a very
strong regulatory structure here and so
it's going to take some time to
figure out how to build that or or
amend that structure so that it works
well not only with the technology of
today that we're seeing
but that it's it it will last
and so it's it's not an easy project we
definitely need to get a lot of people
working on it and not just people at the
sec but people who are investing in this
space people who are
going to be regulated by whatever
regulations we draft um and it's it's
it's not an easy project it's not an
easy project and for that reason i do
just want to bring up xrp i know of
course you can't speak about it directly
but it might be classed as a security so
it would be helpful for the audience to
understand
how are you looking at something and how
are you classing whether classing
whether it's a security we'll start that
how would you decide whether something
is a security and certainly don't want
to speak specifically to any particular
crypto asset but but what i'll say is
that our definition in the us of
security is a broad one
there are some other countries that have
very precise definitions but ours is
intentionally broad
and the idea is we don't want to capture
just things that you know stock or bonds
that you would know our securities but
we want to capture things that someone
might call something different but is
nevertheless
the same idea and so the in the crypto
world the one that's gotten the the
piece of the definition that's gotten a
lot of attention is investment contract
and an investment contract was defined
by something called the howie test which
comes from a supreme court case about
orange groves which now a lot of people
in the crypto world know
and the idea is if you give me money and
i tell you i'm going to build something
all you need to do is give me your money
you're going to get an investment return
on your money just sit back i'll do the
work
and
then
that looks a lot like a security
a securities offering right and so and
so we're gonna treat that as a
securities offering we're gonna regulate
that
and so that's kind of how we look at it
through that lens now there are other
pieces of the definition of security
like what's a note
that may come up in the crypto context
as well
but we're generally trying to capture
anything that looks like one of the more
traditional types of securities and you
said that the sec um takes things slowly
we were speaking earlier and you spoke
about you know you can't walk before you
can run but there are other
cryptocurrencies um that people are
concerned could be classed as a security
and i know you can't speak to any
specifically but from the sec standpoint
do you think that there could be more
and other cryptocurrencies that have the
same future as xrp's going through right
now well again i don't want to talk
about any specific crypto asset but
i i think it's
telling that our chair our chair chair
gensler has said that he sees most
digital assets as being securities
and that may be a different view than i
personally take
but i think there's been a very
expansive reading of the definition of
security not only in the context of
crypto assets to be to be fair
it's been in other areas as well we've
taken a pretty expansive view and so
you know that's that's kind of the world
we're living in so the question that i
say is okay
i might disagree with my colleagues on
how broad that definition should be
but if we're going to use that broad
definition we need to think about what
does that mean
what is that if if you put the label
security on something a whole set of
rules has to follow from a whole set of
requirements follows from that right and
so
how are we going to deal with those
requirements
in the digital asset space where those
requirements could prevent people from
doing things they might otherwise do
so there are a lot of hard questions we
have to answer if we're going to define
a lot of crypto assets as securities as
as some want to do
i want to move on to talk about the
sec's role in terms of protecting the
individual investor so i want to look at
the safe harbor rule
so
does the sec actually have plans to
allow the smaller um
investor that isn't an accredited an
accredited investor the opportunity to
participate in lucrative opportunities
particularly the types of opportunities
that you do tend to see in crypto
well so we have rules in the us that are
a little bit counter to our traditional
approach in the united states which is
that people should be able to spend
their money the way they want you know
they they should
bear the risk and bear the
responsibility but also bear the the
chance to make a return right that that
should be their choice
but we have these rules that say no we
have
private markets and those private
markets are mostly going to be for
people who are wealthy
or
have a high income and for other people
they need to invest in the pro in the
public markets
there's some exceptions to that but
mostly that's how it works and so a lot
of people push back and say wait a
minute you have to have a lot of money
to participate in this whole set
of investment opportunities
and
i think that's a little bit
uncomfortable too i would rather have a
situation where we said no you can
participate over here but you're not
going to get the same protections
in the private markets that you'll get
in the public markets
but
we've been very slow to adjust that now
we actually did recently
make a major
it's a minor step but in a way it's a
major
change in the way we're thinking
to say you know what maybe there's some
people who aren't wealthy
who don't have high incomes who should
nevertheless qualify as accredited so we
open the door to the idea that
if you have the right kind of
educational
certification maybe then you should be
qualified you should be able to qualify
as an accredited investor or maybe
someone will come up with a test
and maybe if you pass that test you
should be able to be an accredited
investor so i'm hopeful that maybe we'll
move a little bit off this wealth and
income test but um it it still it does
make a lot of people very unhappy that
we have those rules in place
because there's a lot of unemployment
right now we're seeing high inflation
and a lot of people do look to
cryptocurrencies as sort of the last
resort the only opportunity right now to
really build long lasting generational
wealth and they do feel ostracized um
you know if they are at the bottom of
the food chain if you want to put it
like that so to what extent is it really
the sec's role to police that to take
away their free choice to decide how
much risk they wish to take as an
individual
well i think you're raising an important
question right from my perspective the
sec's role is a disclosure role right
it's it's to help people get the
information they need to make decisions
for themselves right and they know the
circumstances of their lives they know
what their job opportunities are they
know
um what the potential expenses coming
down the pike are we don't know those
things they know their own risk
tolerance we don't know that so
our job though is to make sure that
someone when there's an information
asymmetry which means that
the person selling you the securities
knows a lot more about what her plans
are than the person buying the
securities we want to even out that and
say you know what person
selling securities you better give
certain information to the person buying
so there's a role there to be played but
there's also a role to be played in
investor education which means that
we're helping people realize you can ask
questions yourself when you're buying
something don't just put your money down
and walk away and assume that everything
will be fine ask questions
if you see something that looks
suspicious go invest your money
somewhere else there are lots of
opportunities out there
and so i think if we if we
try to make the sec
not a merit regulator but
keep it in its role as a disclosure
regulator we really do a better job of
protecting people because then we can
tell them
look ultimately it's your choice and
you've got to do your own homework here
are some material we can provide
educational materials to help them do
that
provide them some lists of red flags
think they should things they should
look out for but ultimately the decision
has to be on the investor herself not on
on the sec sounds like a really healthy
balance one that i definitely support
but how likely is it to see an sec that
looks like that well the sec is not
supposed to be a merit regulator and so
um we really don't have the authority to
do that i think we sometimes wander into
merit regulation territory where we're
you know trying to put ourselves in the
shoes of the investor and say
you shouldn't invest in this or you
should invest in that and it's natural
because we see a lot of really bad
frauds and there is a lot of fraud
in the financial space and the security
space and people do need to be careful
they can really get hurt and so it's
understandable
that you know regulators get concerned
but i think it's important that we
maintain that balance and that when we
get out of balance the people who we
serve say wait a minute you're supposed
to
stick to your role which is not to be a
merit regulator not to tell us what to
invest in but just to help us get the
information we need
and i'd love to understand and learn
about really your experience with
cryptocurrency so how did you first hear
about it do you own any
um
give us the landscape sure well i first
heard about it from
colleagues in my in my last job some of
whom were really interested in in the
crypto world and were doing a lot of
research on it and so
um i learned a lot from them about it
and then when i got to the sec
there were a lot of crypto issues kind
of percolating up to the to the sec and
so those were issues that i was
naturally interested in because i i
think it's always interesting to see
where innovation is happening and then
how that innovation gets handled by
regulators not always well
um
i do not own any crypto i think given
the role that i play it would be
inappropriate for me to do so so i don't
have any crypto
it's a really interesting um
response because i often hear that from
journalists as well um you know it would
be a conflict of interest um but just
finally i'd also love to talk about
cbdc's with you central bank digital
currencies how does that come into play
in terms of regulation what can we
expect is the sec for against it what's
the overview
well so it is a little bit outside the
sec's purview and i will say that i not
only don't speak for the sec i don't
speak for the for the fed and the the
federal reserve is looking into
they've made public that they're looking
into a potential
should we have a cbdc if so what should
it look like
what i will say is that
we have a lot of private stable coins
now um and you know there's been a lot
of growth in that space
and there's
it's something i think to have
competition
and to have not a government
not a government digital currency but
private digital currency
i think is is valuable from a financial
privacy perspective um
and so whereas other countries may
decide that they want a cbdc we might be
able to and i think one of the one of
the federal reserve officials has spoken
about this this the the private stable
coins might fulfill the same role here
in the united states and so that's
something that
um
we should we should welcome that
innovation um and and remember that as
we're thinking about how to regulate
stable coins remember that they can
serve a valuable role in our economy so
just finally how do you expect from
one year to five years from now roughly
i know it's quite a long time the
regulatory framework to look like um
towards cryptocurrencies in the usa you
know it's so hard to look down the road
even a year i think this is going to be
an important year for crypto regulation
because there's been a lot of attention
on it
five years down the road it's hard to
say i mean
congress may at some point get involved
in this space and certainly already
there are a lot of people in congress
who have gotten involved they've dropped
uh bills about you know with different
potential approaches to regulating
crypto
um but if there were actually something
that passed congress that would be
monumental and directing how that
regulation would work
i think what you're seeing right now is
a lot of regulators are planting their
flags by for example bringing
enforcement actions you hear a lot of
statements coming from different
regulators saying
we should have a piece of this
regulatory space but others say no no it
should be ours and so there's a lot of
jockeying for position now which i think
we're gonna
see that continue in the in the coming
years um and and i think those
enforcement efforts will
play a role in
you know allocating the regulatory
pie
but there there are a lot of unknowns
and that's why i really encourage people
who are in this space who are interested
in
how this space is regulated come talk to
me come talk to my colleagues
it is better for all of us if we can
build a regulatory structure that makes
sense that achieves the objectives that
we have the legitimate objectives right
of protecting investors having these
markets function um in a way that's
that's orderly and that
doesn't end up having effects outside of
the crypto markets
so
let's have this conversation together
and let's do this in a wise way
it really should not be viewed
as
the government is just going to set the
regulations and that's how it's going to
be it has to be
an exercise that involves all of us
that's what regulation is supposed to be
about
and so please keep that conversation
happening
i'd love to hear from all of you
this has been fantastic to have this
conversation and i hope that
we'll be able to continue having these
conversations yeah i want to thank you
so much it's been such a pleasure hester
i think these conversations are so
important i know the community are
concerned um about how the future is
going to look so hearing it straight
from yourself um is absolutely brilliant
so thank you so much for coming to talk
to us today it's been my pleasure thank
you thank you everyone for watching and
thank you to exodus waller of course for
sponsoring this and making this happen
if you haven't already then hit the
subscribe button hit the like button and
so you never miss an amazing interview
on my channel thanks for watching
you